pont de la rivière du mât est un ouvrage
construit en 1860 un vieil ouvrage d'art
anciens qui présentent de graves défauts
qui mettent en danger les usagers qui
empruntent cette voie et ils sont
environ 7000 chaque jour à circuler sur
ce pont qui enjambe la rivière du mal
qui relie bras panon à saint-andré et
salazie depuis paniandy pour le
département l'usure du temps ne va pas
arranger la situation
c'est donc devenu urgent de procéder à
des travaux pour réparer la structure de
l'ouvragé alors les travaux consistent à
rendre un niveau de service tel qu'il
est actuellement en toute sécurité ce
qui n'est plus le cas suite au défaut
qu'on a constatée sur la structure donc
on va en particulier
démolir la dalle béton actuelle sur
laquelle roulent les véhicules parce
qu'elle est constituée de deux dalles de
16 cm qui se sont juxtaposés
historiquement mais qui aujourd'hui font
un point mort pour la structure qui est
très pénalisante et une fois qu'on
l'aura démolir l'on reconstruira une qui
ne fera que 16 cm d'épaisseur donc on
aura gagné la moitié du poids en ce
moment c'est très important pour les
ouvrages pour remédier aux défauts qui
ont été constatés des travaux ont débuté
le 1er avril et s'achève dans le 30
septembre plusieurs étapes sont
nécessaires pour arriver à une
sécurisation totale deux ouvrages une
fois qu'on aura des moyens cette dalle
on va lever les structures métalliques
avec des vérins de manière à pouvoir
venir réparer les appuis en particulier
les appuis de la culée rive gauche côté
saint-andré qui actuellement présente
les plus graves défauts au niveau de la
nationale donc ces appuis étaient sous
surveillance mais maintenant
le temps est venu de le réparer et
réparé
complètement un chantier qui nécessitent
une fermeture complète de cette portion
de voie pour les automobilistes mais
également les piétons une déviation qui
concernera également les cars jaunes on
a eu quelques interrogations de la part
de la population notamment en ce qui
concerne les transports en commun et
notamment la ligne estivale de la cirest
donc nous allons organiser très
rapidement une réunion avec la cirest
pour
voir avec le nouvel itinéraire pour
pouvoir se rendre à bras panon et à
saint-andré la circulation elle sera
faite par les voiries habituel
c'est-à-dire depuis paniandy en
reprenant la quatre voies en utilisant
l'échangeur de saint-andré pour remonter
sur la rd48 des travaux qui nécessitent
une fermeture totale du pont de la rd 48
une patience donc car les travaux une
fois terminée c'est un pont flambant
neuf qui sera vendue à la circulation
des panneaux nez et des saint-andréens
ainsi qu'à tous les usagers qui
empruntent cette route